مستمرون معكم مشاهدينا على مدار الساعه
لمواكبه اخر التطورات في السودان مع
اقتراب انتهاء الهدنه تتواصل الدعوات
الاقليميه والدوليه لتمديدها وذلك مع
اسرار طرفي الصراع على موقفهما معاناه
السودانيين طبعا تتفاقم كل ساعه وجهود
الاجلاء تتوصل وتتركز في ظل دمار هائل
لكافه المدن ومع استمرار عمليه اجلاء
العديد من
المواطنين من العاصمه الخرطوم نحو جده
طبعا مع استمرار عمليات النزوح داخل
السودان
[موسيقى]
كما ترون انه مسجد بداد السوق المركزي
تدمر نهائي كل الدكاكين اللي في السوق ما
في دكان من
قوه الانفجار
سيد البرهان وسيد حميد
نسبه لتعب الشعبي وللمعاناه التي عانها
الشعب السوداني
مشاهدينا ساذكر بهذه العواجل التي ترد
الان على الشاشه الجيش السوداني يقول بانه
يعلن تمديد الهدنه 72 ساعه للعمليات
الانسانيه واجلاء الاجانب اذا تمديد جديد
للهدنه بعد ما كانت اتفق عليها على ان
تكون لثلاثه ايام بوساطه امريكيه وبطلب
امريكي الان الجيش السوداني يعلن تمديد
هذه الهدنه طبعا مع استمرار عمليات
الاجلاء ومع المناشدات ان كان الدوليه وان
كان الاقليميه لضروره الاستمرار بهذه
التهدئه ووقف اطلاق النار لدواعي انسانيه
ايصال مساعدات طبيه طبعا واخراج كل
الجاليات الموجوده داخل الخرطوم التي ترغب
طبعا بالخروج من هناك توالت المواقف
الدوليه المؤيده لطلب تمديد الهدنه في
السودان حيث اكدت واشنطن من خلال وزير
الخارجيه انطوني بلينكن على ان الولايات
المتحده تركز بشكل كبير على وقف اطلاق
النار في السودان وان الهد قد ساعدت كثيرا
في تقليل اعمال العنف والمساعده في عمليات
الاجلاء في مقاله بريطانيا ان سفيرها لدى
السودان يتحدث مع طرفي النزاع لحثهما على
تمديد الهدنه محذره من عدم ضمان الاستمرار
في اجلاء الرعايه في السودان بجانبها دعت
روسيا اطراف النزاع في السودان الى ضبط
النفس ووقف اطلاق النار
قال وزير خارجيه جنوب السودان في تصريحات
خاصه للعربيه ان بلاده مستمره في جهودها
لاقناع طرفي الصراع بوقف القتال والتفاوض
مضيفا ان جنوب السودان لم تحصل على موافقه
رسميه من البرهان بشان مبادره ايجاد وان
حكومته تجد صعوبه في الوصول الى قائد
الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دجله هاتفيا منذ
سته ايام
من برهان طبعا من سته يوم حسي الاتصال
انه الناس يكونوا يتصلوا في اي وقت رسلنا
الرئيس الفقير نيابه عن الدول
ماذا تضمنت مبادره
المعنيه بالتنميه
مقتضبه لحل الازمه في السودان
نصت على تمديد الهدنه الحاليه التي تنتهي
الخميس لمده 72 ساعه اضافيه
ودعوه الطرفين المتحاربين لارسال ممثلين
عنهما او مبعوث عسكري الى جوبا جنوب
السودان لاجراء محادثات بينهما ايجاد طلبت
ارسال مندوبي الطرفين الى جوبا يوم الجمعه
المقبل
الساعون للمبادره هم رؤساء جنوب السودان
وكينيا وجيبوتي الجيش اعلن موافقته
المبدئيه على المبادره
وترجيحات بان يكون الفريق شمس الدين كباشي
ممثلا للجيش لا تعليق حتى الان من الدعم
السريع بشان المبادره
من الخرطوم بحري ينضم الينا الصحفي
السوداني محمد اسحاق عثمان محمد سابدا من
الاشتباكات هناك مع اعلان تمديد الهدنه هل
الهدوء سيد الموقف بهذه النقطه التي تعتبر
اليوم يعني نقطه حاميه بين الطرفين
نعم ما قبل قليل تحدثت عن ان بعض الطائرات
تحلق في سماء بحري ولكن سرعان ما جاءنا
الرد من بعض المصادر بعد ان سمعنا
ارضيه قبل قليل
علمنا بانه
اشتباكات تدور في محيط الاذاعه والتلفزيون
باندرمان معلومه ان مبنى الاذاعه
والتلفزيون يسيطر او تسيطر عليه قوات
الدعم السريع ربما كانت هي محاوله قبل
قليل للقذف عبر
الطيران وسرعان ما
ردت عليها المضادات الارضيه واختفت
الطائره من السماء بحري كنا نسمعها قبل
قليل تحلق بمستوى منخفض وبصوت واضح الان
لا وجود لهذه الطائرات يبدو باننا موعودون
بليله ساخنه هذه الليله رغم الهدنه التي
تحدثت عنها قبل قليل
الطائرات هذه الطلعات الجويه يعني التي
رفضناها ايضا بالايام الماضيه هي لقصف
تجمعات
مناطق التجمع واماكن التجمع للدعم السريع
هل يمكن ان تكون مكثفه هذه الليله وكيف
ستؤثر على الهدنه هناك يعني وعلى حركه
الناس بطبيعه الحال
نتوقع ذلك لان الجيش يتحدث عن ان الحسم
سيكون
ساعات قادمه تحدثت في نشره فائده بان
مساله الجيش اعلم بانه قد اعد اعداد كبير
جدا لتامين ولايه الخرطوم خصوصا وان ما
زالت السلب والنهب التي كنت اشرك اليها في
نشره سابقه الجيش ارسل رسائل تصميميه
للمواطنين بانهم سيصبحون خيرا خلال
الساعات القادمه يبدو بان هذا السيناريو
قد بدا قبل قليل لان الساعه
علمنا من بعض المصادر المحدده تبدا من
منتصف الليل اليوم
نتحدث عن قصف جوي وعن عمليات تمشيط بريه
ام يقتصر الموضوع على القصف الجوي ويعني
بمحيط هذه النقطه اليس هناك تواجد سكاني
هل ممكن ان يؤدي الى خسائر بشريه من صفوف
السكان ام ان هناك نزوح تام يعني بظل
الاشتباكات الموجوده
القوات المسلحه منذ الصباح اليوم تتعامل
في هذا الشارع هو يسمى شارع النيل يمتد
منهم درمان وحتى الخرطوم قباله القصر
الجمهوري هذا الشارع تتمركز فيه بعض
الارتفاع التابعه لقوات الدعم السريع هذا
الامر يسبب ازعاجا كبيرا للجيش لان هذا
الشارع تقع فيه كثير من المناطق الحيويه
كما ذكرت قبل قليل مبنى الاذاعه
والتلفزيون مرورا الى شارع النيل الخرطوم
الذي تحاذيه كذلك كثير من
الفنادق موجوده في هذا المكان ووزاره
الداخليه وكثير وزاره الخارجيه وبعض كل
الوزارات السياديه
هذا الشارع
المهم السيادي نسبه لاهميته التي تضم من
خلال هذا الشارع كما ذكرت عدد من نحن
نتحدث عن عن يعني تمشيط منطقه توازي
باهميه محيط القياده العامه وايضا المطار
شكرا لك الصحافه السوداني محمد اسحاق
عثمان حدثنا من خرطوم بحري
لليوم الثالث عشر مشاهدينا تتواصل
العمليات العسكريه في السودان في عده
مناطق من العاصمه الخرطوم التي شهدت
اشتباكات بين كل من الجيش والدعم السريع
واسفرت عن دمار هائل كما نشاهد بهذه الصور
بخارطه المعارك في هذا المثلث الذي يشكل
ما يعرف بمثلث الخرطوم الكبرى في العاصمه
نتحدث هنا عن معارك دائره في منطقتين
نتحدث عن منطقه بحري وانظر بعد حيث نفذ
الجيش السوداني طلعات جويه وغارات على
مواقع للدعم السريع في كل من بحري
واندرمان مقاتلات الجيش استهدفت قوات
الدعم السريع هنا وتحديدا ايضا داخل
الخرطوم داخل العاصمه ولكن في محيط
القياده العامه والتي تعتبر نقطه
استراتيجيه يحاول الطرفان السيطره عليها
ايضا بمحيط القصر الجمهوري حيث تدور
اشتباكات بين الطرفين طبعا هنا
الدعم السريع رد بالمضادات
المضادات الارضيه على هذه الطلعات الجويه
وعلى هذا القصف من قبل الجيش السوداني
الان الى مطار الخرطوم حيث ايضا نفذ الجيش
ومشط مشطت قواته
محيط المطار كما نشاهد هنا بمحيط هذه
النقطه مطار الخرطوم الذي من اول هذه
الاشتباكات هناك اشتباكات دائره بين
الطرفين بمحيط المطار وهناك طبعا بيانات
مضاده بين الطرفين ننتقل الى نقطه اخرى
وهي نقطه الخرطوم بحري اي شمال الخرطوم
وفي ضاحيه كفوري كما نشاهد هنا حيث جددت
المقاتلات الحربيه القصف لاهداف الدعم
السريع في هذه المنطقه منطقه كفوري الذي
يقول بانه الدعم السريع طبعا احبط هجوما
على معسكره بهذه النقطه تحديدا حيث هناك
قوات للدعم السريع وكبد الجيش السوداني
خسائر هائله بهذه النقطه على حد قول الدعم
السريع طبعا ننتقل الى نقطه اخرى والى
منطقه اخرى حيث بي ام درمان اغارت مقاتلات
للجيش على منطقه صالحه هذه المنطقه ومناطق
اخرى ايضا كان هناك غارات عليها هي مناطق
قريبه من سوق ليبيا حيث تتمركز قوات كثيفه
وكثيره
للدعم السريع ويسعى طبعا الجيش السوداني
الى القضاء على هذه القوات اذا كانت هذه
خارطه الاشتباكات داخل الخرطوم حيث تنحصر
الاشتباكات كما شاهدنا بمحيط القياده الع
امه مطار الخرطوم وايضا مناطق اخرى كصالحه
ام درمان وبحري وغيرها
لا اله الا الله
[موسيقى]
تدمر الحله كلها حاجه
مع تعقد الوضع في الخرطوم اصبح الحصول على
صور تظهر حجم الدمار امرا نادرا وكاله
رؤيه نشرت مجموعه من الصور المتفرقه التي
تم التقاطها اليوم لاثار المعارك في
الخرطوم بحري حيث تظهر مشاهد الدمار بشكل
كبير اثر المعارك دعونا نتابع مشاهدينا
بعض من هذه الصور ونعود
معنا مشاهدينا من اندرمان الصحافي شهد
نادر استاذ نادر يعني
اليوم الصوره من ام درمان خصوصا وان الجيش
اعلن عن تمديد الهدنه كيف هذه الصوره من
هناك هل هناك استمرار القصف والمعارك ام
هناك التزام يعني بهدنه ولو كانت متقطعه
مرحبا الوضع
كما هو ما تزال المناوشات اصوات المضادات
الارضيه بمكينه الاخرى طيران يحلق
منذ فجر فجر الامس بشكل متقطع
كما هو الحال اليوم
قناتي العربيه
والحدث مقاطع من سوق ام درمان السوق مغلق
بشكل شبهي كلي مشاكل بدات تواجهها
السودانيين في توفير حاجاتهم
الاساسيه حاله الذعر وهلع كبيرين نتاج
انتشار مايورم في السودان ومجموعات تسعه
طويله او عصابات النهضه المسلح تحت تهديدا
السلاح الذي تروع المواطنين بدات بوادرها
اليوم بحسب ما افادات شهود عيان في ماسوق
برمان انه قد كان هناك تخطيط لهجوم على
السوق من جانب هذه المجموعات تخطت
تصدت له
مجموعات
اهليه اليوم حركه طفيفه في شوارع مدينه
درمان هي للامانه هي افضل من الايام
الماضيه بشكل ملحوظ بدات الطمانينه تدوب
بعض الشيء في
سكان مدينه ام درمان ولكن ما يزال الاصوات
الدويه المضادات العربيه اصوات الطائرات
اصوات الاشتباكات مع الاخرى من جنوب غربي
ام درمان من شرطها
يتقاطر الى المسامع السودانيين تفضل انظر
من التي تعتبر ثاني اكبر
من احدى المدن الاساسيه والمناطق الاساسيه
في العاصمه الاداريه الخرطوم اليوم اين
تتركز نقاط الاشتباك بين الطرفين هنا وما
اهميتها بالنسبه ان كان للدعم السريع او
للجيش السوداني بما اننا كنا قبل قليل
يعني نشرح خارطه الاشتباك بين الطرفين
كما تعلمين منطقه
شرقي ام درمان وتحديدا محيط الاذاعه ومقر
محيط مبنى الاذاعه والتلفزيون المطيل على
شارع النيل في مدينه ام درمان هو ظل محل
مناوشات منذ هذه الاشتباكات في يومها
الاول كذلك احياء البستان والمنصوره
والنخيل ومدينه ام بدع وتحديدا منطقه ودن
اود البشير في جنوب مدينه ام درمان هذه
ايضا ظلت محل او مناطق عمليات عسكريه منذ
انقلاح هذه هذه اللام هذه الاحداث ما بين
الفينه والاخرى تكثر المناوشات يسمع
للمواطنين هناك وبالاخص سكان المناطق
المتاخمه لهذه
المناطق اصوات المضادات اصوات الدول
الاسلحه
حركه النزوح من ام دورمان هل نتحدث عن
حركه نزوح ما زالت مست مره فهذه الطريق هل
يعني اليوم تستخدم لمرور اي من عمليات
الاجلاء ام لا
كما تعلمين فان الطريقه الرابط ما بين
السودان
ومصر هو يمر عبر مدينه ام درمان شمالا الى
الولايات الولايه الشماليه ومنها الى
المعابر الحدوديه التي تربط ما بين
السودان ومصر ظلت الحركه هناك
الى حد ما
لا يوجد معدلات نزوح كبيره في
اوساطهم باستثناء سكان المناطق المتاخمه
او نعم هي المتاخمه او التي بجوار مناطق
هذه هذه الاشتباكات غالبيه اهل اهل
المدينه متمسكون بالبقاطه رغم ان هناك
حاله هدوء
وليست كليه ولكن افضل من لا شيء يرون انه
من الافضل لهم البقاء في
منازلهم البقاء في احيائهم وعدم مقادرتها
سنبقى نتابع طبعا معك ومع كل الموجودين
داخل السودان
بانتظار مع ما يعني معرفه اما اذا كانت
طرفان سيلتزمان بهدنه نوعا ما بهذه
المنطقه تحديدا شكرا لك الصحافه شهد نادر
من ام درمان
[موسيقى]
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه ان المملكه
تمكنت مساء اليوم من اجلاء 200 شخص من
رعايه الدول الشقيقه والصديقه من السودان
الى جده واضافت الخارجيه السعوديه ان
اجماليه ما تم اجلائهم من السودان منذ بدء
العمليات وصل الى نحو
1744 شخصا منهم 119 سعوديا والبقون من 76
جنسيه هذا واكدت السعوديه ان الاشخاص
الذين تم اجلائهم اليوم هم من الولايات
المتحده ومصر والبحرين والصومال ولبنان
وافغانستان وفلسطين وجامبيا ونيجيريا
وباكستان وكندا وتايلاند
على ظهر سفينه جلاله الملك الرياض العربيه
تواكب وصول رعايه القادمين من السودان هذه
السفينه التي تحمل على متنها اكثر من 200
شخص وصلت للتو الى قائده الملك فيصل
البحريه وهي وقفت بالفعل بشكل تام وها هي
هذه اللحظات الان في انتظار النزول
الرعايه لكن هناك بروتوكول بحري معروف لدى
القوات اي او اي قوه بحريه هي بصعود قائد
الاسطول ويحيي الطاقم الملاحي للسفينه
ويحييهم ايضا لوصوله او سلامه وصولهم على
الانجاز الذي حققه اذا ايضا ننقل الصوره
من الجهه الاخرى وهي سوره وصول الرعايه
الذين وصلوا من جنسيات مختلفه اسيويه
وكذلك افريقيه وايضا بعض
الجنسيات الاوروبيه التي وصلت
على هذه اللحظات وهم قادمين بومبورت سودان
وهي سفينه قد غادرت ليله امس ووصلت في هذه
اللحظات
الى ذلك مشاهدينا اعلنت مصر ان الجهود
المبذوله لتسهيل عبور النازحين من الاراضي
السودانيه اسفلت عن النجاح في تسهيل عبور
اكثر من 16 الف شخص من غير المصريين الى
داخل الاراضي المصريه حتى اليوم اغلبهم من
السودانيين الذين بلغ عددهم 14 الف مواطن
فروا من المناطق التي تشهد مواجهات واعمال
عنف بالاضافه الى اكثر من 2000 اجنبي من
خمسين دوله
وست منظمات دوليه
معبر ارجين البري يفصل بين الحدود المصريه
والسودانيه افتتحس سبتمبر عام 2016 لنقل
البضائع والركاب يقع على مسافه 850 كيلو
مترا شمالي الخرطوم يستوعب
7500 مسافر يوميا واكثر من ثلاثمائه شاحنه
بات يمثل طوق نجاه للفرينه من اشتباكات
السودان عبر منه الالاف من السودانيين
والمصريين هربا من القتال بعد اجتياز
المعبر يتجه المسافرون الى مدينه اسوان
الوصول اليه يتطلب رحله محفوفه بالمتاعب
تستغرق نصف يوم للوصول اليه من الخرطوم
ومده مماثله للعبور الى اسوان ونظرا
لصعوبه الوضع في السودان سمح للسودانيين
بعبوره بلا تاشيره مسبقه
قال وزير الخارجيه البريطانيه ان الوضع في
السودان قد يتفاقم في الايام المقبله كما
اكد ان بلاده ستواصل الدعم للرعايه
البريطانيه
النار ليس مقدمه بالضروره للسلام والوضع
في السودان من الممكن ان يتفاقم في الايام
المقبله ونحن سنواصل الدعم للرعايه
البريطانيين لذلك نحن موجودون في بورتودان
ولدينا مسؤولون دبلوماسيون في مصر
واثيوبيا والمملكه العربيه السعوديه
[موسيقى]
الازمه في السودان موجه هجره جديده صحيفه
التلغراف البريطانيه تتوقع نزوح اعداد
مهوله من السكان وبالتالي زياده في عدد
المهاجرين غير النظامين
فبريطانيا وحدها قد تشهد لجوء اعداد كبيره
من السودانيين الامم المتحده تقول ان عددا
كبيرا من اللاجئين السودانيين فروا الى
بلدان المجاوره منذ بدء الازمه مع توقعات
بنزوح مئه الف سوداني الى تشاد
و170 الفا الى جنوب السودان بالاضافه الى
مصر وجمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى
بدورها تناشد الامم المتحده جميع الدول
بجوار السودان ابقاء حدودها مفتوحه امام
الذين يبحثون عن الاماني والحمايه
[موسيقى]
اجرت مشاهدينا العربيه مقابلات حول
الجاليه العراقيه التي عادت من السودان من
داخل مطار بغداد الدولي فلنستمع الى هذه
المقابلات اللي رجعنا هسه احنا تقريبا 240
واحد لكن طبعا عندنا هناك موجودين موجودين
ظلوا عالقين والله ضلوا عالقين
بالسودان للمسافات بعيده يعني اللي ساكن
بسناره صعب يوصل للخرطوم واللي ساكن
القضارف صعب يوصل يعني حركه التنقل في
اثناء المعارك تصير صعبه جدا صعبه وصارت
ظروف الحرب طبعا وعشنا ايام صعبه
والسوداني برضو عاشوا ايام صعبه بس لما
شفنا انه بالتلفزيون الاجلال وكل
المواطنين الاجانب اللي قاعدين يعني
انبسطنا وقلنا ان شاء الله هم يعني احنا
يعني هم نطلع والحمد لله يعني سهلت امورنا
وصلنا بالسلامه الرحله عامه مشت بسلاسه
طبعا المسافات طويله من الخرطوم الى بورت
السودان فوق 12 ساعه بالحافله
اكو يعني مثلا اماكن مشحونه ضرب ومضروب بس
احنا كنا قاعدين انا بالخرطوم بالماكينه
بمكان اسمه معموره اركويت بتسمع ضرب وقصف
بس مو قريبه من يمك
تجدد القتال في اقليم دارفور المضطرب اصلا
غربيه السودان ويبدو ان هذا القتال ياخذ
ابعادا قبليه معارك عنيفه واشتباكات
وصفاتها الامم المتحده بالزاميه شاهدت
شهدتها تحديدا منطقه الجنينه غرب ولايه
دارفور وهي العاصمه هنا بين عناصر من قوات
الدعم السريع والجيش ومستخدمين مختلف
انواع الاسلحه القتال العنيف تحول الى
نزاع بين قبيله المساليد الافريقيه
والقبائل العربيه استخدمت فيها اسلحه
ثقيله ايضا عشرات القتلى مشاهدينا من
المدنيين سقطوا ومئات الجرحى اصيبوا ولم
يتم اسعافهم بسبب طبعا الاوضاع الصعبه
وانتشار المسلحين القبليين في اجزاء واسعه
من مدينه الجنينه عدا عن تزايد اعمال
النهب للمؤسسات الحكوميه ومقر المنظمات
الامميه وسوق الجنينه وحرق عدد كبير من
المنازل وفق مسؤولين في حكومه غرب دارفورد
الى جانب طبعا توزيع الاسلحه بين
المجتمعات المحليه الذي يزيد من الفوضى
والعنف بطبيعه الحال هذه التطورات دفعت
بعدد من سكان الجنينه الى الفرار باتجاه
الحدود السودانيه وتحديدا الحدود
السودانيه
رغم اغلاق الحكومه هناك لهذا المعبر ومنذ
عقدين يعيش اقليم دارفور اضطرابات امنيه
كبيره تخللتها انتهاكات واسعه تسببت بمقتل
قرابه 300 الف شخص ونزوح حوالي
2.5 مليون شخص
[تصفيق]
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من الرياض محمود
لعوته الكاتب الصحافه السوداني استاذ
محمود يعني ما تشهده دارفور هو امتداد
للمرحله الثالثه بتاريخ هذه المنطقه من
الصراع طبعا باتفاقيه السلام كان يؤمل
يعني ان ينتهي هذا الصراع الى انه يتجدد
بين الحين والاخر اليوم مع الانهيار
للدوله المركزيه ومع تشتت مركز القرار هل
يمكن ان نتوقع انفلات اكبر بهذه المنطقه
نعم نعم صحيح يعني كلامك صحيح يعني هي
المنطقه دي اساسا كانت منطقه صراعات قبل
قبل ذلك يعني ان كانت انطلاقات التمرد
فيها كثيره فيها اكثر من حركات مسلحه فيها
صراعات قبليه عنيفه تاريخيه قديمه قبل
تاسيس الحركات المسلحه لكن دعيني اقول لك
يعني لماذا يعني يعني اشتدت المعارك في
مدينه بالذات يعني انا اعتقد في
حركه استراتيجيه من قوات الدعم السريع
بالاستيلاء على هذه المدينه اذا في حاله
حدوث اي تطورات في الخرطوم يعني تكون
سلبيه بالنسبه لقوات الدعم السريع طبعا
المدينه هذه هي حدوديه يمكن تكون قريبه من
ليبيا وتكون قريبه من تشاد وهي منطقه
جمركيه طبعا عدد سكانها يمكن اكثر من 170
الف نسمه بتسكنها قبائل متعدده منها الفور
بعض القبائل العربيه
يعني مختلط من القبائل في غرب السودان
فانا اعتقد الاقتتال هذا هو الغرض منه
استيلاء قوات الدعم السريع على هذه
المدينه التي تكون خط رجعه في حاله اي
ظروف حصلت في
المعارك في الخرطوم وكما تعلمين يا اختي
سبق وان
قائد الدعم السريع الحميدي جلس في هذه
المدينه يمكن اكثر من اربع شهور قبل هذه
الاحداث وما كان الغرض من هذا
البقاء في هذه بانه هذه المنطقه تعتبر
كانها خزان يعني
المسلحين الذي ممكن ان يعني يلجا اليه
الدعم السريع وايضا في حال خرجوا من
العاصمه ممكن ان يتجهوا نحو هذه المنطقه
ولكن بالمناطق الحدوديه عندما اتحدث عن
ليبيا هناك عدد كبير من المرتزقه هناك خطر
ان يدخلوا عبر الحدود ويشكل ايضا قوات دعم
اساسيه للدعم السريع من تشاد ايضا هناك
قوات انفصاليه ممكن ايضا ان تشكل حاله
جديده داخل هذا الصراع خصوصا مع تواجد
مناجم الذهب هناك مع صراع القبلي ان كان
على الارض وان كان على الموارد وبالتالي
كل هذه الصوره المعقده الممكن ان تجعل من
هذه المنطقه يعني قنبله جديده بالداخل
السوداني
وهي في الاتجاه في هذا الاتجاه هي في هذا
المسار انا اعتقد الجنينه حتكون
المعارك المناطق المعارك بعد الخرطوم او
بعض اي منطقه تانيه من السودان
وانا بعلق يعني يمكن قد يعني الانباء او
تشير بعد المعلومات الغير رسميه بانه قد
تكون هنالك قوات لتعم السريع على الحدود
التشاديه او على حدود الليبيه ونحن نعلم
تماما انه كان من ضمن مطالب قائد الدعم
السريع قبل ان تنفجر هذه الاشتباكات طالب
بالسماح له بملاء مطار في هذه المنطقه
فانا اعتقد كل المؤشرات العسكريه تشير
بانه المعارك او الاقتتال العنيف في هذه
المدينه
الغرض من قوات الدعم السريع هو
جعلها مرتكز ثاني رئيسي له في حاله
كما ذكرت لك وجود خط رجعه كما تعلمين يعني
القوات الدعم السريع لها امتدادات في
ليبيا يعني انها يعني كما لنا وكالات
الانباء والصحف والتقارير الغربيه بانه
لديها علاقات قويه مع القائد الليبيه حفتر
وحتى نحن سمعنا بعد برضو الانباء الغير
رسميه في بدايه اختتال كان هنالك نيه من
حفتر ان يمد حميتي ببعض الطائرات او
الاسلحه او المداد ولكن
القائد الليبي نفى هذه المعلومات التي
وردت في
القنوات الفضائيه وفي الصحف المحليه علي
حال الموقف يعني
غوله ولا نقدر نستطيع ان نقيم الاحداث
هناك
معرفه موازين القوى داخل العاصمه يعني
كلها شحيحه وترى انه هناك اشتباكات ولا
نعرف الكف لمن تريح يعني شكرا لك استاذ
محمود الكاتب الصحافه السوداني حدثنا من
الرياض
لاول مره تكشف روسيا رسميه عن دور قوات
فاجنر في السودان بعدما اعلن وزير
الخارجيه الروسي سرج ان للسودان الحق في
الاستفاده من خدمات فاغنن كيف عززت روسيا
حضورها في السودان فلنتابع هذا التقرير
الصراع في السودان يفتح باب مواجهه جديده
بين روسيا والغرب وموسكو تكشف رسميا ولاول
مره عن دور مجموعه فاغنر هناك وزير
الخارجيه الروسي ومن المقر الاممي في
نيويورك كشف انني السودان الحق في
الاستفاده من خدمات فضلا عن كلام لافروف
رئيس فارنير اكد استعداد مجموعته للتدخل
في حال طلب الشعب السوداني ذلك
سوداني
فسارسل بالتاكيد مهمه حفظ سلام الى
السودان من قبل شركه فاجنر العسكريه
الخاصه ولو كانت فاجنر هناك اعتقد ان
الحرب لم تكن لتبدا في السودان فاجنر لا
تبدا الحروب انما تنهيها دائما
لكن كيف تطورت العلاقات السودانيه الروسيه
وصولا الى تعزيز دور باكنير موسكو اسست
لوجودها في السودان منذ عهد البشير من
خلال تحسين شروط عمل شركات الطاقه الروسيه
واخرى تنشط في مجال التنقيب عن الذهب
والثروات الاخرى ايضا ابرز ما عزز الوجود
الروسي في السودان هو سلاح الذي اصبحت
بسببه المصدر الرئيسي للجيش السوداني
فتحولت الخرطوم الى ثاني شريك عسكري
لروسيا في القاره الافريقيه بعد الجزائر
بعد تلك الخطوات وتحديدا عام 2017 وقع
السودان اتفاقا مع روسيا لانشاء قاعده
عسكريه على البحر الاحمر تستضيف سفنا
روسيه بما في ذلك سفن تعمل بالوقود النووي
على ان يتمركز فيها 300 جندي اتفاق
خلق الغرب بدوره في تعزيز الاستراتيجيه
الروسيه في افريقيا وعلى سواحل البحر
الاحمر
ورغم وقف العمل بالاتفاقيه بعد الاطاحه
بالبشير الى ان مصالح موسكو في السودان
دفعتها الى الابقاء على علاقه وثيقه مع
اللاعبين الاساسيين خلال السنوات الماضيه
لكن تميزت مع احمدتي خصوصا على خلفيه
تزايد التقارير حول امداد قواته بالسلاح
والمساعده العسكريه الروسيه من خلال قوات
فاغنر محاسن حضاره العربيه
من بارز مشاهدينا ينضم الينا الصحافي
والكاتب السياسي ماجد الخطيب استاذ ماجد
وجود وتعزيز روسيا لوجودها داخل السودان
وتحديدا اتحدث بانها بدات منذ عام 2017
عبر فاجنر
لكي تكون السودان احد نقاط الارتكاز بشرق
القاره الافريقيه من المعلوم بان العديد
من القوى الدوليه تستغل الازمات والحروب
لتعزيز وجودها ونفوذها ان كان الاقتصادي
والسياسي اليوم استغلال الازمه الداخليه
السودانيه الى اي مدى يخدم تعزيز الوجود
الروسي في القاره الافريقيه الذي هو بدا
اصلا يعني بالسنوات الماضيه
نعم بدايه تحيه طيبه لك وللساده المشاهدين
جميعا يعني اتفق معك مع نقطه مهمه جدا بان
روسيا هي تحاول من الحوالي عشر سنوات
تقريبا تعزيز وتكريس وجودها في القاره
الافريقيه وان تقوم بعمليه يعني انزياح
للقوى الغربيه الموجوده هناك وبالتحديد
فرنسا
لذلك انشات هي مجموعه من القوى المرتبطه
بها وعلى راسها طبعا تاتي هنا حيث توسع
قوات فاجنر من تواجدها في عده دول افريقيه
ليست فقط في السودان وانما كما تعلمين
كذلك ايضا في ليبيا ومالي وجنوب وجمهوريه
جنوب افريقيا وسط افريقيا وبالتالي
هذا الصراع الروسي الغربي يعني موجود
ومكرس منذ حوالي عقد من الزمن الان بعد
سقوط او دعينا نسمي بين قوسين يعني مع بدء
ثورات الربيع العربي وخاصه في يعني منطقه
افريقيا اقصد هنا ليبيا بالدرجه الاولى
والسودان بالدرجه الثانيه ليبيا كانت كما
تعلمين روسيا ترتبط مع مع يعني عقود سلاح
ونفط تقدر باكثر من 5 مليار دولار
وبالتالي مع سقوط نظام معمر القذافي سقطت
تباعا هذه العقود الان روسيا تحرص على
الحفاظ على مكتسباتها ايضا الموجوده في
السودان والتي تم انشاؤها منذ عام يعني
عام 2010 وتعزز هذا الوجود كذلك في عام
2017 عندما زار البشير روسيا وقع اتفاقات
عده كما اسلفت في مقدمه الخبر والتقرير
اضيف الى ذلك ايضا نقطه اريد ان اتي على
ذكرها ان وزاره التعدين السودانيه
بزعامه البشير انذاك حكومه البشير
اوقع طاقيات مهمه تنتج اثرها منذ حوالي
يعني بضع سنوات منذ عام 2017 حتى هذا
اليوم وقعت اتفاقات مع شركه ام انفيست وهي
تعتبر الشركه الام بحسب التقارير الصحفيه
بان الشركه الام شركه موريكولد وهذه
وبالاضافه الى شركه كوش
وهذه الشركات
التي ذكرتها لك هي شركات روسيه تحمل
الجنسيه الروسيه وهي مملوكه بشكل او باخر
لقوات فاجنر وبالتالي يعني تواجد روسيا في
السودان ياتي لتحقيق مجموعه من الامور
والمكتسبات المهمه اول المكتسبات يعني
اضافه الى المكتسبات الماليه الاقتصاديه
السياسيه هناك مكتسب استراتيجي من المعلوم
بان بالفتره الماضيه هناك صراع بين القوى
على المنافذ البحريه وعلى الممر ممر
التجاره العالميه اليوم السودان لها موقع
استراتيجي على البحر الاحمر تعزيز الوجود
الروسي هناك الى اي مدى ممكن ان يضر يعني
بهذا
بالممرات المائيه العالميه ويضغط على
الجانب الغربي
يعني روسيا عزيزتي تحرس من خلال تواجدها
في السودان من خلال الذراع فاجنر على
استكمال ما بداته مع عمر البشير عندما تم
الاتفاق على انشاء قاعده بحريه عسكريه على
على ضفاف او على البحر
اقصده بانها تريد ان تستكمل مبادئته مع
عمر البشير وهذا في حقيقه الحال يمثل احد
مصادر الصراع بين روسيا والغرب لانه عندما
تسيطرين انت على البحر الاحمر يعني انك
تسيطرين بشكل او باخر على ثلث التجاره
العالميه هذا الممر البحري مهم جدا اكثر
من ثلث التجاره العالميه تمر من خلال
البحر الاحمر وبالتالي هذا يمثل نقطه صراع
جدا بالنسبه للقوى الغربيه اوروبا اقصد
طبعا وبالتالي وايضا الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وحتى ايضا تركيا تركيا ايضا
كانت لها مساعي لان تكون لها يعني بؤره
للتواجد او نقطه تواجد وارتكاز في منطقه
البحر الاحمر وهذا ما حرصت روسيا على
استبعاده واقصاء جميع الاطراف او اللاعبين
الجدد الذين يحاولون التواجد على هذا
الممر البحري المائي الخطير جدا وبالتالي
مجمل يعني مجمل ما اود قوله بان الصراع
حول
نقطه حساسه جدا بالنسبه لروسيا ولن تسمح
بتصوري بان يعني
لاي طرف من الاطراف الاوروبيه السيطره
عليها وبالتالي
حتى هذه اللحظه يعني
من ضمن الازمه السودانيه روسيا بشكل صريح
لم تدعم
اي هي بالضروره
تريد هذا
الامميه والاخطاء الامريكيه بالتعاطي مع
الملف السوداني وبالتعاطي مع يعني هي
الاخطاء التي تتحدث عنها حتى داخل
الامريكي اليوم والداخل الاوروبي
بالمسار الانتقالي شكرا لك الكاتب الصحفي
والسياسي ماجد الخطيب من باريس
دعت اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر في
السودان اطراف الصراع الى تسهيل عمل
المنظمات الاغاثيه وحركه العاملين في
القطاع الطبي داخل البلاد وحذر مدير
الاعلام في اللجنه في تصريحات للعربيه من
خطوره الوضع الانساني بسبب نقص المستلزمات
الطبيه والمياه والكهرباء
اود ان نغتني مع هذه الفرصه ونتحدث على
شاشتكم يدعو كافه الاطراف والطرفين
لكيسير عمل المنظمات الانسانيه
وكذلك حركه العاملين في القطاع الصحي حتى
يستطيعوا الوصول الى المستشفيات والتقديم
الرعايه الصحيه كما ادعوهم لتيسير اولئك
الذين يبحثون عن المياه
للتوفير الكهرباء هناك حاجه لصيانه محطات
المياه والكهرباء واذا لم يتمكن
السودانيون من
الاعتناء بمتطلبات
الصيانه لمحطات الكهرباء والمياه هذا
سيؤدي منعدام المياه والكهرباء في ارجاء
متعدده من الخرطوم وكذلك المدن المتضرره
بالقتال
خطر جديد يزيد تعقيد الوضع في السودان
منظمه الصحه العالميه حذرت من خطر انتشار
فيروسات قاتله من مختبر صحيح قريب من
مناطق الاشتباكات في الخرطوم
المعمل القومي للصحه العامه في الخرطوم
الذي يقع على بعد امتار من القياده العامه
للجيش التي تشهد اشتباكات مسلحه متكرره
خلال الايام الاخيره المعمل اصبح مصدر قلق
على المستوى الدولي حيث اعلنت منظمه الصحه
العالميه على لسان المدير التنفيذي لاداره
الطوارئ بها الدكتور مايكل ريان ان الفرق
الميدانيه تقيم الوضع
الخطوره تكمن في احتواء المعمل على عينات
من فيروسات وبكتيريا خطيره كالحصبه
والكوليرا والتي اذا ما انتشرت في الظروف
الصحيه الحاليه
ستتسبب في كارثه لن يستطيع اي من الاطراف
المتصارعه علاجها هناك شحف المستلزمات
الطبيه والادويه
والعاملين في القطاع الصحي يمكن ان
يتحركوا بامان من منازلهم الى
المستشفيات المدير العام للمنظمه الامميه
حذر من انه في حال حصول كارثه بسبب المعمل
البايولوجي فان المرافق الصحيه لن يكون
بمقدورها استيعاب مصابين
30% فقط من مستشفيات الخرطوم تعمل في ظروف
ماساويه ولن تستطيع التعامل مع اي تسرب
فيروسي في حال وقوع المعمل القومي في ايد
غير امينه
كثير من المستشفيات التي خرجت عن الخدمه
والسبب يعود لانعدام الموظفين والعاملين
والمستلزمات الطبيه ما يزيد الوضع خطوره
هو قرب المعمل القومي للصحه العامه من
مناطق ذات كثافه سكانيه عاليه انسنا
الماسي العربيه
عبر الاهالي في مدينه ام درمان عن مخاوفه
حقيقيه من استمرار عمليات السلب والنهب
بسبب الاقتتال الدائر بين قوات الجيش
والدعم السريع واظهرت لقطات فيديو خاصه
بالعربيه مشاهد تظهر اغلاق المحلات
التجاريه في الاسواق الرئيسيه مع اعاده
فتح عدد قليل منها واستحضر شديد مما يطالب
فيما يطالب طبعا الاهالي الحكومه بتوفير
الحمايه اللازمه وتامين حياه السكان في ام
درمان ووقف الاعمال العنف
واي شارع فيها ناس شغالين شغل مره كسروا
الدكاكين
والشوارع كلها
السوق كله تكسر السوق كله مقفله
بعكاكيز جميع السوق يعني الناس
لكن الوضع سيء سيء للدرجه بعيده خلاص في
السوق
والله الوقود
ولا ما تشتغل لا هو نفس الحاله شايفين جاي
طيور
عربيتين ثلاثه يقفلوها
يعني
بضاعه جديده خاشه ما في دقيق بيجي ما في
حاجه هسه حاليا في الوقت الحالي ده اسال
الله يا اخي ارفع
ما زالت دمار والموت يخيمان على السودان
اسره المعارك المستمره بين الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريع تداعيات الحرب تلقي بظلالها
ايضا على التجار واصحاب
مياومات بعد توقفهم تماما عن العمل
فلنتابع
سماء لا تهدا
وجدران بيت لا تستر زارتهم قذيفه
دمرت في طريقها ما استطاعت وتركت شظاياها
اثرا
رصاصات ايضا لم تبخل على المكان كارثه
خلفت وفاه شهد اهلها على وقوعها بل الرئيس
يا ريش الريش ده طوال خش عليه ضروري
يعني لحظات الاخيره
موت في لحظه كما الفقد وقع على هؤلاء
الاطفال
توفيت والدتهم امام اعينهم يتفقدون ما حل
بمنزلهم او ما خلفته الحرب على طفولتهم
اختار اهل الدار البقاء فلا خيار للنزوح
على بعد مسافه دمار لم يبقي شيئا خراب على
مد البصر كارثه بالدليل قذيفه حرقت
الممتلكات هنا وهشمت ابواب الرزق
قوه الانفجار كل الدكاكين ده ابوابها
انكمشت وتحشمت من فوق يعني ما في حاجه
المهن اليدويه يشكون حالهم يحتجون امام
نقابتهم لا يجمعهم هنا سوى البطاله الان
وادوات جمدتها الحرب ووضعتهم بين فكيها
الناس دي كلها سافرت مرقت هجرت مرقت لكن
مجاعه قد تطال الجميع استيراد الاحتياجات
الغذائيه توقف اما المخزون الحكومي فيشك
على الانتهاء وفق الامن الغذائي السوداني
مقومات الحياه ان توفرت حاليا فاسعارها
مضاعفه
معارك حرمتهم من حركه تجاريه كان يعتاش
عليها السودان المنهك اقتصاديا اصلا غيداء
السالم العربيه
كما ترون انه مسجد بدايه السوق المركزي
تدمر نهائي كل الدكاكين اللي في السوق ما
في دكان من
قوه الانفجار وجينا
السيد البرهان والسيد حميد تبعينا يوقف
الحرب نسبه لتعب الشعبي وللمعاناه التي
عاناها الشعب السوداني
مشاهدينا ساشير الى هذا العاجل الذي ورد
على الشاشه قبل قليل عن البنتاجون بان
اعداد الامريكيين الذين يرغبون بمغادره
السودان قليلا نسبيا للتذكير بان اعداد
الامريكيين الموجودين داخل السودان
يتجاوزون ال 15 الف من حاملي الجنسيه
المزدوجه اتحدث هنا عن غير الرسميين
والدبلوماسيين اذا كان هذا التحديث
للبنتاجون حول
الامريكيين الذين يرغبون بمغادره السودان
ضمن المرحله الثانيه من عمليه الاجلاء الى
ذلك اعلن الجيش السوداني تمديد الهدنه الى
72 ساعه للعمليات الانسانيه والاجانب
والاجلاء طبعا للاجانب يبدا سريان هذه
الهديه هدنه اعتبارا من تاريخ انتهاء
الهدنه الحاليه اليوم الخميس هذا هو اعرب
الجيش السوداني عن اماله في التزام من
وصفهم بالمتمردين في اشارات نقوات الدعم
السريع بمتطلبات سريان الهدنه واوضح الجيش
السوداني ان تمديد الهدنه تم
باستجابه لمساعد صعوديه امريكيه لتهيئه
الظروف لاجلاء المقيمين من مختلف الجنسيات
التوصل الى هدن في السودان وان كانت مؤقته
مساء دولي بهدف اغاثه المدنيين وتوفير
ممرات امنه للعالقين بين نيران الطرفين
المتصارعين
بين ساعات وايام معدوده تراوحت المده التي
شهد فيها السودان هدنا اخترقتها طلقات
البنادق والمدفعيه وتضغط عده جهات دوليه
لابقاء الهدنه لكن دون تقديم مبادرات خاصه
بدوله ما
الولايات المتحده قالت انها تواصل العمل
مع طرفي الصراع لتثبيت وقف اطلاق النار
والامر ذاته ينطبق على الاتحاد الاوروبي
نعمل عن كتب مع الامم المتحده على الازمه
في السودان ونامل ان نتمكن من التوصل لوقف
اطلاق النار والمساعده على ارجاع السودان
الى مسار الانتقال نحو حكومه مدنيه الضغط
الاقليمي كان الابرز في هذا الملف وتحديدا
من الهيئه الحكوميه للتنميه ايجاد والتي
تضم دول شرق افريقيا والسودان عضون فيها
ايجاد لم تعلن تفاصيل المبادره لكن من
بينما كشف عنه انها نصت على تمديد الهدنه
الحاليه مده 72 ساعه اضافيه وبمبادره من
رؤساء جنوب السودان وكينيا وجيبوتي طلبت
ايجاد ارسال ممثلين عن الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع الى جوبا عاصمه جنوب
السودان لاجراء محادثات
طلب الرئيس ان تجري محادثات حول امكانيه
وكيفيه ايقاف الحرب ثانيا هذا الاجتماع
المقترح يمكن ان يكون داخل السودان او
خارجها رئيسنا تحدث مع البرهان والبرهان
تلقى هذا المقترح وقال سنرد عليه ونحاول
تقديم المقترح الخطي ايضا لقائد قوات
الدعم السريع
وفي الخرطوم تضاربت الانباء حول الرد على
المبادره فبينما اعلن الجيش موافقه مبدئيه
على تمديد الهدنه نفت وزاره الخارجيه ان
تكون القوات المسلحه قد قبلت التفاوض مع
قوات الدعم السريع
[موسيقى]
والان مشاهدينا الى موجز لابرز الاخبار
الدوليه حيث اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
عن توجيه ضربه مركزه باسلحه بحريه عاليه
الدقه على مواقع تمركز احتياطات القوات
الاوكرانيه وفي السياقه ذاته افادت الدفاع
الروسيه بان قواتها سيطرت على عده مناطق
جديده في الضواحي الشماليه والجنوبيه
لبخمود مؤكده ان الجيش الروسي ابسط سيطرته
على اربعه احياء جديده في ضخمه
قال امين عام حلف الناتو ان اعضاء الحلف
قدموا بان اعضاء الحلف قدموا دعما غير
مسبوقه لاوكرانيا وان الدعم الغربي
لاوكرانيا سيجعلها بوضع قوي لمواصله
استعاده اراضيها
بالتعاون مع الولايات المتحده قدم اعضاء
النيتو دعما غير مسبوق لاوكرانيا وتم
بالفعل تسليم اكثر من
98% من المركبات القتاليه التي وعدت بها
اوكرانيا وهذا يعني اكثر من
1550 عربه مدرعه
و230 دبابه ومعدات اخرى بما في ذلك كميات
هائله من الذخره كما قمنا بتدريب وتجهيز
اكثر من تسع كتائب مدرعه اوكرانيه جديده
وهذا سيضع اوكرانيا في وضع قوي لمواصله
استعاده اراضيها المحتله
اكد وزير الخارجيه الصينيه بان اول
محادثات هاتفيه بين الرئيس الصيني مع
نظيره الاوكراني
هي منذ بدء العمليه العسكريه الروسيه
الخاصه تعد خطوه مهمه نحو تسويه سياسيه
للازمه مشيرا الى ان الخطوه التي اتخذتها
الصين تمثل مدى التزام الدوله الثابت
بالحيازيه قائلا ان موقف الصيني يعزز
عمليات السلام والمفاوضات
اكد الرئيس الروسيه فلاديمير بوتين بان
الدول الناميه تعاني اكثر من غيرها بسبب
العقوبات المفروضه على تصدير الاسمده
الروسيه مؤكدا خلال اجتماع مع رئيس
الرابطه الروسيه لمنتجي الاسمده بان
العقوبات على بلاده تم فرضها من قبل الدول
التي لا تحتاج الى الاسمده مشيرا الى ان
الاسواق الناميه في افريقيا وامريكا
اللاتينيه واسيا تضررت بشكل كبير
ظهر الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان على
شاشه تلفزيونيه لاول مره بعد مرضه وذلك
حسب ما نقلته وكاله اي بي الفرنسيه حيث
شارك اردوغان في فيديو مباشر مع نظيره
بوتين للحديث حول مساهمه روسيا في انشاء
محطه للطاقه النوويه في جنوب تركيا
اعلنت البحريه الامريكيه بان الحرس الثوري
الايرانيه احتجز ناقلت نفط ترفع علم جزر
مارشال مطالبه بالافراج الفوريه عنها وقال
الاصول الخامس للبحريه الامريكيه بان
الحرس الثوري الايراني احتجز ناقله النفط
اثناء عبورها في المياه الدوليه في خليج
عمان مطالبا الحكومه الايرانيه بالافراج
عنها فورا بدورها قالت البحريه الايرانيه
بان الناقله حاولت الفرار بعد اصطدامها
بزورق ايراني مما اسفر عن فقدان شخصين
واصابه اخرين مشيره الى ان مدمره ايرانيه
اوقفت الناقله واقتادتها للسواحل
الايرانيه
الى بلجيكا حيث تدرس الحكومه تسليم
دبلوماسيه ايراني محكوم بالسجن الى ايران
قال رئيس الوزراء البلجيكي ان حكومته تدرس
طلبا ايرانيا بتسليم الدبلوماسيه الايراني
اسد الله اسدي المحكوم بالسجن 20 عاما
مقابل افراش طهران عن عام الاغاثه بلجيكي
يقضي عقوبه السجن لمده اربعين عاما بتهمه
التجسس هذا واودينا اسدي بالتخطيط لهجوم
على تجمع معارض لنظام طهران في فرنسا عام
قال الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
بان رئيس جو بايدن يشكل خطرا على
الديمقراطيه واضفت راب على صفحته على موقع
غير كفوء ولا يعرف كيف يدير البلاد واعتبر
الرئيس السابق بان الولايات المتحده في
حاله تدهور خطير بسبب قياده شخص عديم
الجدوى على حد تعبير
مشاهدينا اختم معكم هذه الساعه الاخباريه
طبعا
تغطيه العربيه مستمره لاحداث السودان
نستكمل هذه التغطيه مع الزميل طاهر بركه
شكرا والى اللقاء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات